señor galliano primeramente darle el
pésame por la pérdida de un amigo y
cuéntenos para quien dentro y fuera de
colombia no conozca quién fue darío
gómez porque ha sido tan importante su
figura en la música popular
bueno rodríguez me hace mucho saludarte
y a toda la audiencia de france 24 a ver
comenzamos en en esta línea teórica
musical
aquí en colombia se llama música popular
se llama música popular porque describe
el sentimiento
común de la gente lo que en realidad la
gente vive en su día a día eso fue lo
que lo que hicimos con mi amigo y colega
darío gómez ya hace 40 años más o menos
y a él se le conocía comúnmente como el
rey del despecho de dónde viene este
apelativo y cuál cree que es el legado
de su figura para el género bueno mira
rodrigo es una palabra que es extraída
prácticamente de esta música yo yo no
estaría muy seguro pero creo que que esa
palabra no estaba en el diccionario y
fue adaptada a la real academia de la
lengua me parece pero pero
la palabra despecho
se le dio un significado
a aquellas personas que sufrían
una decepción amorosa por ejemplo
entonces de ahí nació ese apelativo esa
manera de llamar a esta música
y en que se caracterizaba esa música en
concreto que es lo que le hizo tan
popular entre el pueblo colombiano pero
también en buena parte de latinoamérica
a ver la música popular
nuestra la que llamamos hablar es
descriptiva de el sentimiento común de
la gente
y lo que lo que de pronto algunas
personas que padecían algunas de estas
cosas de desamor no podían
manifestarlo porque no eran ni
compositores y cantantes
entonces recurrí a
a la interpretación de nosotros a lo que
decíamos nosotros a través de las
canciones que muchas eran historias
nuestras pero también eran historias de
la gente que a veces nos escribía nos
mandaba cartas o correos como fuera
diciendo lo diciéndolo los que había paz
lo que lo que le había pasado en su
diario vivir y nosotros hacíamos una
canción así fue
entrando la música popular y haciendo
una conexión con el pueblo sea
descriptivo de lo copian